Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
"La scuola nelle nuvole"
questo è il sogno che io ho pensato
e ho avuto da sempre, direi.
Soprattutto da quando, 14 anni fa -
io insegno italiano e latino,
quindi materie assolutamente umanistiche -
io mi sono recata all'Università
degli Studi di Milano,
dal prof. Degli Antoni,
grande guru della multimedialità
e dell'informatica,
per presentare insieme ai miei studenti
un lavoro che avevo fatto con loro,
un powerpoint, 800 slide:
avevamo lavorato tantissimo, i ragazzi
avevano letto tantissimo in latino,
avevano letto tantissimo la storia,
ci eravamo divertiti moltissimo,
avevamo presentato questo powerpoint
assolutamente illeggibile,
assolutamente orribile;
però eravamo tutti contenti
perché lo presentavamo ad un grande guru
dell'informatica e della multimedialità.
Lui ci ha ascoltato con estremo interesse,
e poi ha detto ai ragazzi:
"Avete studiato, vi siete entusiasmati?"
Loro hanno detto: "Assolutamente sì".
A me ha chiesto
se avevo raggiunto lo scopo.
Certo: i ragazzi avevano studiato latino,
avevano studiato storia,
avevano studiato italiano,
ci eravamo divertiti e avevamo
lavorato insieme molto, molto bene.
Dice: "Benissimo!
Adesso prenda questo lavoro,
lo metta in un cassetto
e lei, professoressa,
incominci a studiare
cosa vuol dire la didattica multimediale".
Era nel '98, io ero già su bene di età,
sono abbastanza vecchia,
con una storia comunque universitaria,
una storia anche di studi notevole,
per il mio livello, insomma, della scuola
e mi sono spogliata
di tutta questa veste di docente
e ho cominciato a fare la studentessa,
e ho cominciato a studiare,
a studiare insieme
agli assistenti, nei laboratori,
alle persone che incontravo
in questo piccolissimo ufficio
in questa università,
un ufficio dove c'erano
pochissime sedie, due scrivanie
e tantissime tesi di laurea
tutte accatastate,
dove tutti quanti si incontravano,
c'era sempre la porta aperta,
se uno studente passava
veniva preso e scaraventato,
messo a sedere a parlare
insieme alle altre persone
e ci potevano essere persone
di grandissimo livello,
grandi manager, grandi studiosi.
E lo studente diventava il protagonista
e cominciava a parlare,
interloquire con queste persone
che mai avrebbe potuto incontrare,
poi, nella propria vita.
E la loro progettualità
e la loro creatività
si sviluppavano anche nel corso del tempo,
perché noi ci incontravamo nella rete,
ci incontravamo anche al di fuori
di quelle quattro pareti.
Questo stesso metodo, io,
ho incominciato a sentirlo come esigenza
e a trasportarlo nel mondo della scuola,
quando io ho visto i miei ragazzi
che stavano incominciando
a parlare un lessico
che io non capivo più,
che noi docenti non capiamo più,
perché loro parlano
con strumenti di comunicazione
che noi non conosciamo.
Per cui quando nel 2010
è uscito, appunto, l'IPad in America
e io avevo sentito il prof. Rocca
che parlava degli e-book,
questi libri digitali stranissimi,
ma si parlava sempre
in forma molto molto teorica,
io ho deciso di prendere
degli e-book reader,
cioè dei lettori di e-book,
e ho pensato di metterli nella classe,
vedendo veramente che cosa si poteva fare
con questi e-book reader,
cioè se effettivamente
rivoluzionavano la didattica
come i grandi universitari dicevano.
È chiaro che i miei colleghi
erano molto perplessi
da questa mia decisione,
perché loro, oltre che dire:
"Ma i ragazzi non sanno più leggere,
non sanno più scrivere,
non sanno più far di conto",
non riuscivano ad andare oltre,
perché loro si trovavano
nella stessa condizione
in cui mi sono trovata io
quando sono entrata
in quel famoso ufficio.
Parlavano un lessico che non si capiva;
noi abbiamo un lessico specialistico,
virtualità, rete, che cosa vuol dire?
Noi della nostra generazione
non siamo in grado di comprendere a fondo
i meccanismi dei nostri ragazzi
e quindi ci dovevamo spogliare
della veste dei professori
e diventare noi stessi studenti
e farci guidare dai nostri ragazzi
in questo mondo virtuale.
Per fare questo ho deciso
di prendere degli IPad,
in America erano usciti
e in Italia non erano ancora arrivati,
quindi stiamo parlando
del maggio del 2010,
ed ho deciso di farli mettere tutti
in una classe, la mia IV,
questi ragazzi che voi vedete,
in una IV liceo scientifico
che erano con me da quattro anni.
Ho chiesto dei finanziamenti
all'Ufficio Scolastico Regionale
della Lombardia,
hanno creduto in questo progetto
e abbiamo dato a tutti gli studenti,
e a tutti i docenti, questi tablet,
senza sapere nulla, senza avere
nessuna letteratura di riferimento.
E quindi abbiamo cominciato
a lavorare insieme,
a scoprire che cosa potevamo fare
con questa tecnologia,
perché non basta mettere
la tecnologia in classe, come si pensa,
inondare le scuole di tecnologie.
Questo è dannosissimo,
se non si sa che cosa farne
di queste tecnologie,
se non si cambia il metodo di lavoro.
Quindi noi ci siamo messi
a lavorare con i nostri ragazzi,
in forma laboratoriale.
Se voi entrate nella mia scuola,
nelle mie classi,
i banchi non sono mai messi
in forma tradizionale:
i miei studenti ascoltano
molto poco, in forma passiva,
ma lavorano loro stessi, insieme a noi.
Ho tolto i libri di testo,
e ho messo tanti libri di testo cartacei
nella biblioteca della classe,
perché i ragazzi
devono leggere moltissimi testi,
devono leggere moltissime fonti:
le fonti digitali, che loro scoprono
avendo la connettività in rete
grazie al loro iPad
o qualsiasi tecnologia similare
e devono anche integrare queste conoscenze
con i libri di testo cartacei
che loro devono riamare,
che loro devono rileggere
e questo soltanto
grazie alla personalizzazione
che noi facciamo nella nostra
didattica sui ragazzi.
Se i ragazzi si sentono protagonisti,
se i ragazzi non sono
passivamente nel banco
ad ascoltare noi docenti che parliamo,
ma sono loro che creano i loro percorsi -
dei percorsi, badate bene,
interdisciplinari,
perché vedete, questo strumento
che tutti noi conosciamo
diventa inevitabilmente il loro zaino,
dove hanno tutto a disposizione.
Con un clic possono andare
nel mondo di internet
e interscambiarsi documenti,
possono lavorare in gruppo
pur non essendo fisicamente lì a scuola.
Quando sono a casa,
loro interagiscono con noi continuamente.
I miei studenti sono malati?
Ma che problema c'è:
mi chiamano in Skype,
mi chiamano in Facetime
e loro sono a scuola
come se fossero presenti alla lezione.
Non possono perché non hanno
la lconnessione in quel momento?
Non c'è problema:
i miei studenti registrano le lezioni,
vanno nel laboratorio di informatica,
fanno il video della sperimentazione
e la mandano via web
ai loro compagni che sono a casa,
i quali possono rielaborare a casa
tutto il materiale che hanno registrato,
tutti gli appunti che hanno preso,
possono chiederci
spiegazioni continuamente
collegandosi con noi in rete.
E possono avere a disposizione
tutto il materiale che noi docenti
mettiamo a loro disposizione
in questi ambienti virtuali in internet.
Quindi noi interagiamo tutto nelle nuvole,
noi mettiamo tutto il materiale possibile
e facciamo in modo
che ci sia la possibilità,
da parte degli studenti,
di creare il loro sapere.
Sono loro che scrivono,
sono loro che devono leggere,
sono loro che non possono più avere
un solo testo che li rende
monoindirizzanti.
Cioè, il testo unico non fa altro
che far ripetere la lezione,
ma non acquisirla in maniera consapevole.
La consapevolezza delle conoscenze avviene
solo se si hanno tante tante fonti,
e noi dobbiamo insegnare
ai nostri ragazzi,
che parlano un linguaggio
a noi sconosciuto ancora,
perché loro sono in Facebook,
loro sono nel mondo virtuale,
loro sono nella globalizzazione,
loro sono in vie che noi non conosciamo.
Ecco che allora noi dobbiamo avvicinarli,
stare accanto a loro
e farci noi guidare in questo mondo;
ma nello stesso tempo,
noi docenti dobbiamo dare a loro
tutti quei paletti,
tutti quei punti di riferimento
che a loro servono
per creare la loro conoscenza,
per cui loro rielaborano
tutti i loro testi,
noi li correggiamo continuamente,
insegniamo loro che andare in Internet
significa anche conoscere
le leggi del copyright,
selezionare i siti
scientificamente validi.
Vedete, ultimamente nella scuola
si parla tanto di contenuti
e di libri scolastici
e si pensa che si possano fare
i libri scolastici, o dei contenuti,
semplicemente fatti
dagli studenti e dai docenti.
No, dal mio punto di vista
questo non è possibile.
I contenuti devono essere
scientificamente validati
e devono essere dati dagli editori
che ce li devono fornire
in modo completamente nuovo.
Siamo noi che poi,
con i nostri studenti in classe,
li elaboreremo;
e i nostri ragazzi
impareranno che alcuni siti,
pur bellissimi per loro come Scuola.it,
non sono validati scientificamente
come il sito della Treccani.
Quindi noi dobbiamo insegnare
ai nostri ragazzi
che possono andare in Youtube,
possono andare a cercare le immagini,
possono andare nel mondo di Google;
ma devono sapere che esistono delle leggi,
dei diritti d'autore,
esiste il copyright,
esiste il Creative Commons,
e loro si devono adeguare a queste leggi.
Ma questo serve per il loro futuro,
serve per imparare a diventare
dei veri cittadini digitali,
che è quello che la società oggi vuole,
che i nostri ragazzi
utilizzino queste tecnologie,
che possono diventare lo strumento
grazie al quale possono costruire
tutti i loro percorsi,
però devono conoscere anche i limiti
che questi strumenti devono dare
nella loro crescita
e per la loro personalità.
Quindi noi abbiamo lavorato
con questi ragazzi,
veramente a strettissimo gomito
e immaginate, loro hanno
i loro quaderni virtuali,
quindi possono scrivere su questi tablet
e catalogare tutti i loro quaderni.
Possono crearsi i loro e-book multimediali
possono crearsi
la loro biblioteca virtuale,
all'interno dei quali
metteranno le loro conoscenze
e creeranno il loro sapere.
Noi professori che cosa dobbiamo fare?
Appunto, guidarli
e stare accanto al loro percorso;
studiarli, osservarli,
dare delle indicazioni
e valutare la loro modificazione,
ciò che loro imparano
e le competenze che vanno ad acquisire,
perché vedete, nel mondo del lavoro -
questo lo sappiamo tutti -
non chiedono più lo studente che sa tutto,
ma chiedono lo studente
che ha flessibilità , che ha autonomia,
che ha capacità di risolvere i problemi,
che ha la capacità di personalizzare
il proprio modo di lavorare
sulle esigenze dell'azienda;
e quindi, noi dobbiamo
insegnare questo, agli studenti.
E questo avviene tramite il seguire
anche ciò che l'Europa ci dice,
le otto competenze-chiave europee,
che permettono proprio la laboratorietà
e quindi lavorare con i ragazzi
sempre in gruppo,
la condivisione del materiale,
la collaborazione
e la co-creazione, cioè creare insieme.
E non c'è nessun problema,
noi non perdiamo di carisma.
I professori pensano che magari, oddio,
io devo scendere dalla cattedra
e mettermi con i ragazzi,
ho perso il mio carisma.
Assolutamente no.
Noi acquistiamo un grandissimo carisma,
perché nel momento in cui chiedo
al mio ragazzo
di aiutarmi a risolvermi
un problema tecnologico
perché ne sa molto, ma molto più di me,
lui accetterà molto più volentieri
la guida che io darò loro
per creare il loro sapere,
le loro conoscenze,
quelle conoscenze tradizionali
che il ministero ci dà
e che noi sappiamo
essere fondamentali per i ragazzi
e che noi andiamo a recuperare
utilizzando semplicemente quegli strumenti
che sono ormai l'ambiente
utilizzato dai nostri ragazzi.
È un metodo di studio
che abbiamo messo in atto,
abbiamo scritto un libro
alla fine della IV liceo
di questi ragazzi,
l'abbiamo presentato
in moltissimi convegni,
l'abbiamo aperto ad altre classi.
La mia scuola, in I liceo, da 270 ragazzi
è arrivata a 520 in un anno.
Io insegno in I U, 18 classi prime
con trenta ragazzi davanti.
Abbiamo oggi 9 classi nel mio liceo
che seguono tutte la stessa metodologia,
l'abbiamo aperta ad altre scuole,
25 scuole stanno seguendo
il nostro stesso metodo,
con degli step determinati e definiti.
L'università Bocconi
ci ha seguito, ci ha studiato,
ha visto la metodologia
che noi utilizziamo,
ci sta monitorando,
quindi siamo sottoposti
a questionari, a valutazioni;
e documentiamo tutto
ciò che noi abbiamo come risultato,
perché vediamo, per la
prima volta, i nostri ragazzi
veramente contenti di venire a scuola.
Ecco, non si annoiano più,
loro si sentono veramente protagonisti:
questo è un elemento che già rende
questa sperimentazione e questo metodo,
per noi docenti, eccezionale.
E soprattutto, noi docenti
abbiamo imparato, anche,
a lavorare tra di noi.
Credete, questo è miracoloso.
Cioè, il docente che lavora
con gli altri docenti
è miracoloso, ma è necessario,
perché se non ci aiutiamo
non potremo mai affrontare
un nuovo modo di concepire la didattica.
E quelle pareti,
così come avveniva in quella stanza
del prof. Degli Antoni,
si disgregano,
perché noi lavoriamo nelle nuvole,
interscambiamo tutto il materiale.
Per cui queste 25 scuole
che interagiscono tra di loro,
scambiano il materiale
come se fossero
nella stessa identica classe
e io posso seguire le lezioni
di una classe che è in Sicilia,
quella della Sicilia
segue le lezioni che faccio io,
ci interscambiamo tutto nelle nuvole.
E questo credo che sia, veramente,
un modo nuovo di fare scuola
e un nuovo modo di far crescere
i nostri ragazzi.
È nato un centro studi, su questo,
che si chiama Impara Digitale,
un centro studi che ci permette
di far interagire tante realtà diverse:
non sono tutti professori,
ma ci sono anche dei personaggi
che fanno parte del mondo
dell'information technology,
che credono in questo profondissimo
cambiamento della didattica
e del profondissimo cambiamento
che deve esserci nella scuola,
questo movimento culturale
che noi stiamo portando avanti dal basso.
E con questo centro studi,
stiamo facendo formazione in tutta Italia.
Abbiamo già formato oltre 1.000 docenti,
e stiamo portando avanti qualcosa
che noi crediamo possa veramente
aiutare i nostri ragazzi.
Ecco, questo è quello che noi vogliamo
e che grazie a questo metodo,
e a questo nuovo modo di fare didattica,
pensiamo di poter ottenere.
Questo è il mio sogno,
cioè "la scuola nelle nuvole".
Grazie.
(Applausi)